let me give you some words okay some  words that you put somebody in how  differently people look at that person  okay uh if somebody calls somebody cue  that person's career may be over okay if  somebody calls somebody cue that  person's query could be over if somebody  calls somebody a racist that person's  career may be over if somebody calls  somebody an anti-semite right that  person's career may be over election  denier anti-vax how many of these do we  have we have so many of these that we  can put there right and what that does  is unfortunately get some people to be  quiet and say well I'm definitely not  going to touch up on that topic no I  still think the average person doesn't  fully trust  the the voting process and by the way I  think that's on the left and right I  think the average person doesn't trust  whether their vote really matters as  well as whether the system they really  trust or not I think till today people  on both sides still feel that way